mark hamill you had the granddaddy you
add I mean one of the biggest secrets in
cinema history the dark thing episode 2
so how long did you have to keep that
secret
well the contrast was the one we did
Star Wars nobody cared you know I read
it and I I gave it to my friend to read
I said that this is the goofiest thing
I've ever read and then you call he said
you're right it is goofy can I give it
to Meredith I said sure I passed it all
around by the second film that's when
their scrutiny became more intense and
there was a wonderful substitute
revelation in that scene and the way we
filmed it Vader said you don't know the
truth obi-wan killed your father and the
idea of Alec Guinness being the the real
villain I thought wow what a spectacular
twist and it's just as you see in the
film no search your feelings you know
it's true wallop the hand goes off the
director urban courier took me aside he
came to my dressing room actually and he
said I'm going to tell you something I
know it George Lucas knows it when when
I tell you you'll know it but if it
leaks
we'll know it was you I said what what
and he handed me the piece of paper that
said I am your father
I just shocked I said is that it was
that true he said well you search your
feelings and we're gonna play it like
that so oh my gosh dad Vader
and then I was paranoid because I
thought you know it was way before
social media and all of that but I had
to keep the secret for about a year and
a half I didn't tell Carrie I didn't
tell well you know telephone telegraph
telecaring
Harris and I would test her if you
really wanted to get something out fast
you asked Carrie to keep it in the
confidence so at the screening when that
happened
Harrison turned to me and said hey could
you didn't [__] tell me that I only
used it for historical accuracy yeah I
mean I was so thrilled because I mean I
don't like having the the burden of that
I talk in my sleep you know really
dangerous miss Harrison like your
impression actually once said to me
today it's very accurate
[Music]